just outcomes coverage of the 2019 video
World Cup got underway today with round
one of course we have news reports and
live coverage with our partners the
chest bras covering everything that is
going down in Canton Mon Sisk but I'm
also going to be scouring the games
played and try to pick one of my
favorites each day if I can to bring you
a video highlight of what went down so
here today in round one I chose the game
between Shawn press as white versus a
Dingley rent as black let's dive in and
see why I chose this one obviously a
Sicilian right has to be an opening that
I played for many many years my life but
jokes aside the closest iliyan not
something you see played against the
world's elite guys like DRA Dingley run
that often at least not outside of
wrapping and blitz but Shawn press goes
for this and then with a typical g3 nice
c6 Bishop g2 we're in a very very common
close Sicilian that you can find
information about pretty much anywhere
you want to look up and use opening
databases g6 d3 Bishop g7 and now on
Bishop III we see Dingley Wren choose
the move that I would say as somebody
who played this my entire chest career
that the move rook to b8 really kind of
won the battle really in the late 90s
the early part of the turn of the
century as kind of the most principled
very very popular way that the best
fighters in the world chose to play this
this position before that the move 694
was also very common of course pushing
East six or five and even Knight f6 are
all theoretically sound moves here but
rook to b8 is a very principled approach
and in every Sicilian you're looking for
your rook and Bishop to work together on
the Queen side whether that's a dragon
sacrifice you know on c3 or things with
the rook on the B file and the pressure
that this Bishop exerts eventually
causing some discomfort for white this
is just a very principled thing for
black to do and in a close Sicilian
where you don't have white doing the
normal things of opening up the
structure which is the difference or
should it open in a closest iliyan right
it makes even more sense that black can
be ultra aggressive on the Queen side
and launched their plans so that's what
black does here with rook b8 and b5 note
that there's there's no discoveries here
on an undefended knight on c6 so don't
don't get too frisky on me if you try to
push this pawn black will pretty much
always just capture with the knight and
save the piece in the process so instead
we have Knight GD 2 and after the very
common b4
as we said black is being very
aggressive and principled 90 d1 is met
by a move that although this is not the
first novelty in the position this was
the first moment where me analyzing the
game myself someone who's played these
positions a lot started just kind of
taking notes of what Dingley red was up
to he played the move h5 now this is not
just a bullet approach on chess calm
right he's not just trying to play h4
and h3 which by the way he kind of is if
if white does something of uncon
secuence here you might see h4 and and
try to open the HDL you might even see
h3 because it does cause some weird
things you can imagine if the pawn gets
to h3 and the bishop has to move then
the knight comes into d 4e 5 maybe
hitting that bishop so there actually
are some really aggressive plans with
Harry the H pawn here but that's not
really the idea h h5 is played so that
you actually stop White's plan of
eliminating your best piece now what's
an example line i can give with that
well if you play the move Knight f6 for
example instead in these Sicilians white
will play Bishop h6 and immediately try
to make make you part ways with your
favorite minor piece on the Kings side
and even if those positions are at the
end of the world that's it's not ideal
for black and is certainly not a dynamic
way for black to be playing for a win so
h5 has played in many ways to stop that
idea in addition to maybe the threats
you have white plays h3 and this is the
way you stop h4 is because what press is
saying here is if you play h4 now now I
can respond with g4 obviously without a
move like h3 g4 it's not a possibility
because you'll just lose the pawn right
so h3 is played to protect the pawn h4
would be met with g4 and that would
actually be a very good thing for white
there's no way you want that as black
because White's gonna get f4 and have
this very very nice kind of big pawn big
pawn opportunity here on the Kings side
a pawn storm is coming
so instead after h3 now we get our first
actual novelty Dingley red played the
movie 6 and when I said novelty kind of
anticlimactically there because it
wasn't necessarily a groundbreaking idea
Knight f6 is the more typical move here
the game I saw played by maybe the most
strongest most recognizable player to
the chess community these days was a
game where Alexei Serrano the young man
from Russia who played in our own junior
speeches championship won a nice game is
black with the move Knight f6
but but this move very obviously blocks
your bishop
and it's it's often not your favorite
square for the piece and these close
Sicilians if you have your way the
reason II 6 is is the favorite of a lot
of people who play these positions as
black is because it's by far the most
flexible move right it it doesn't
relinquish your control over the central
white squares it doesn't block your
Bishop on g7 like a move like Knight f6
or even another move that's been played
in this position e5 would write blocking
the bishop it also over protects against
White's only real eventual attacking
idea on the closest iliyan which which
is to eventually play f4 and f5 and so
ii 6 is almost always the preferred
choice if you have the opportunity to do
it because it's the most flexible thing
you can do is black for all those
reasons i just listed so Dingley run
play d 6 and after castles Knight g e7
f4 we get a 5 again just very
disciplined right now you're gonna
continue to do what you would normally
do on the Queen side which is gain space
and then know how to use it right and
after rook b1 castles we got a tough
moment where white played the move g4
and as a former professional chess coach
here to admit that I've taught lessons
for many many years in and out of
people's homes and I would often tell
students in these types of positions to
be very careful when you push that G
pawn in front of your king because it's
a pawn they can't go back and it
instantly changes things
ding li Ren did the response here that
every Sicilian player needs to make note
of and put it in their pocket I'm gonna
show that in a second but it's it's most
effective even meaning the move Dingley
Ren did that I'm about to show because
white played g4 very often I would
advise students in the way you would
want to play these positions is don't
push this pawn until you're sure you can
really execute on something on the
kingside from that perspective and
analyzing with an engine I actually
would have preferred Knight f2 and even
a slower approach Bishop f3 trying to
put the King on h2 sometimes Y can even
try to play c3 before this night comes
into d4 so you know if black does
something Bishop d7 Bishop a6 or both
moves sometimes black goes out of out of
sorry white goes out of the way just to
control the center and really make sure
that once you eventually do get this
move you can bring everybody with gusto
to this side of the board to try to keep
the attack going so it's it's hard for
me to criticize g4 on a principled level
it's very common for white in the
closest Ilion
but Dingley run from here on out really
puts on a clinic that you should make
note of not just as a sicilian players
black but any time you're playing
positions with a black fient oh sorry a
kingside fiend keto it doesn't have to
apply just a blacks position it can also
work for white but the idea is you you
you put the kibosh on the pawn storm
right after the Jeep owners push with
the move f5 now why is this so key well
the first thing is that it cinches this
pawn on f4 so that this Bishop on e3 is
now a Franken pawn forever stuck looking
at the rear of this pawn on f4 so you
immediately say that this battery that
white works so hard to build will never
see the light of day again you also are
inviting White's position to become more
and more open by playing f5 you're
saying you played g4 and now you can't
take it back I want to open up
everything here cuz I actually think
your King is gonna be weaker than my
King when all is said and done so again
another key reason why you do this plus
the pressure it puts on white is
actually gonna force white to exchange
which is gonna help black complete his
development as well which happens in a
lot of these close Sicilians just like
it did here takes takes by the way note
that I did analyze this for a blog you
can you can follow me on chess comm I
write blogs over there pretty much
anytime I do a video I try to give you
guys the detailed written analysis that
I've been doing here for the last hour
and a half and I also noted that once
again I think Knight f2 was probably the
best move for white one fun line to show
for white is you would never want to
take here as black and try to get a
discovery because here come the
attacking ideas with f5 sacrificing the
pawn but just blowing things open
something like this to just get the
attack on the King really shows you how
you could get in trouble here as black
right so those are the things that close
Sicilian and grand-prix attack players
fantasize about right weird fantasies to
have I know but that's what they
fantasize about but that that's not
really gonna be what what happened if
Knight UPS you probably didn't run place
a move like 94 was what I analyzed would
have been best to to return the favor of
maintaining the tension by maintaining
detention yourself but okay so f5
I still think white should have played
Knight up to rather than taking and
closing because now this is really a
great example of what I already kind of
foreshadowed White's King is gonna be
more open than blacks you put the kibosh
on this battery all of whites dark
squares are only temporarily guarded
because there's pieces but if you start
imagining these pieces come
off the board look who's a sitting duck
over here right so that kind of
foreshadows what Dingley Wren did here
this should be six a natural developing
move that gains a tempo 95 a natural way
to grab the center I also analyzed in my
blog that I think Bishop d5 would have
been kind of interesting but 95 Bishop
f2 and here's where it gets fun 1984 the
most principled thing to do in these
closest ilion's you have a center Square
use it even at the risk of double pawns
these pawns are so incredibly useful
they're they're strangling White's
options on the dark squares the D pawn
itself is is not a targetable weakness
and actually also helps control the
center so you can already get the
feeling that this looks like a great
position for black especially with
squares like III and c3 calling the name
of that knight on d5 rook e1 was played
Bishop f7 and after Knight B - I really
like Dingley wrens move here I gave it
an ex clam because it shows that it's
not just how optically good a square
looks and even the potential you might
have to grab some material but one thing
you have to consider whenever our trades
gonna happen is do you get more squares
available to your pieces after the trade
or does your opponent and if the answer
is you very often that's a trade you
should prioritize and start calculating
and the movement was played here 93 not
only does that because any trade here is
gonna open up devastating dark square
bishop problems but it also points out
that the the material itself is really
not relevant for black right this double
pawn did its purpose to to grip the dark
squares and now force white to part with
kind of his most important defensive
piece so much so that I don't know if I
was playing white I might have sacked
the exchange just to keep that Bishop on
the board
even if I'm worse but press apparently
wasn't afraid of his dark Square
problems and after Queen takes rook e8
Queen f2 he may have wanted to change
his mind
rook takes one obviously Brooke take c1
would have lost a piece just a forcing
line so Queen take c1 is played and a
lot of people could play this position
now for black look how much fun this is
gonna be Queen b6 check the dark squares
are about to get surgical up in this
right just so many squares - not enough
time for white king h2 rook e8 with
tempo Queen f1 now if you look at this
game with an engine and I did put some
lines into the blog black for example
could take here play Queen e3
and then and then execute a second-rank
attack we're probably every single
pashka falls but why how could you ever
give up a bishop like that right so I
don't I don't care what the engine says
I think d5 is a brilliant move by
Dingley Wren again it strangles the only
potentially active square for the white
knight on b2 just awesome and and so
this night going to a for not not a fun
way to improve your night Queen d4 King
h1 and now I'm gonna let you pause the
video I'm gonna try to do this in every
game at least once to try to guess
blacks move if you want really a great
example of just full board awareness
recognizing your opponent's weaknesses
and we've already been foreshadowing the
weak dark squares the weak King but then
not missing an opportunity to take
advantage of it even if optically it's a
little strange right to make a
retreating move and that move is Bishop
f8x clam not only is it a retreat of the
bishop to come to new diagonals that
hurt things but you know that Bishop
just did it just got out of the way of
the first lady she's coming to h8 to use
the h-file against the king just awesome
rook c1 was played Bishop d6 I think
Queen h8 as strange as it seems to go
back to g7 followed by Bishop d4 was
actually the fastest way for Dingley run
to win the in fact there's like
literally no way to stop a ship before
here there's no way to deal with Bishop
before and just everything is falling
here so that was probably the fastest
but playing Bishop e6 to win f4 makes
sense
c3 takes Knight takes the f4 pawn fell
and after Brooke c2 Queen AJ check white
didn't resign I think he actually played
King G 1 and then resigned after having
made his own move but there's several
ways to mate I think the most clear is
something like Bishop h2 and then Queen
h4 and Queen g3 noting that Bishop h2 if
King h1 I think you have Bishop g3
opening up both Queen h2 and rook e1
winning the Queen so that would have
been a fun way for things to end but as
we said white pretty much resigned I
think right after playing kim jiwon
himself so just an awesome game I hope
you enjoyed it as much as I did
definitely my favorite win by one of the
world's elite here in the first round of
the feeding World Cup while I have your
attention let me remind you that you can
check out all the news and action all
the reports that we're gonna be ringing
to you from Conti Mon Sisk
just go to chest comm slash news we will
have
full coverage of this event one of the
most exciting events because it's truly
a knockout that eventually decides a
champion and who's covering it live well
our partners are the chess bras they
have gasser as their guest so that's
pretty exciting they're up early we know
it's hard for those guys they don't
really have a bedtime but they don't
really wake up that happily either but I
hear their show is going well regardless
and we hope you check them out so thanks
for tuning in
give us give us a like if you will give
us a subscribe to our YouTube channel
get at me on Twitter if you have any
questions and we will see you around on
chest comm